في اول قصف جوي بالعام الجديد استهدفت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه مواقع
عسكريه لنظام الاسد وميليشيات ايران
وبالتالي بكوره الغارات الاسرائيليه على
سوريا في 20 23 القصف استهدف مستودعا
للاسلحه والذخيره تابعه للمليشيات
الايرانيه لنظام الاسد داخل مطار دمشق
وموعدات لوجستيه وصلت حديثا للمليشيا في
محيط هذا المطر قصف اسفل عن سقوط قتله من
الميليشيات الايرانيه وايضا ضابط للنظام
السوري كانوا متواجدين داخل بمحيط مطار
دمشق الذي بات الهدف الاول للغارات
الاسرائيليه الغارات الاسرائيليه دمرت
ايضا مدرجا كانت تستخدمه الطائرات
الايرانيه لنقل الاسلحه والميليشيات
واخرجت المطار عن الخدمه وذلك لساعات قبل
ان يعود للعمل مجددا
[موسيقى]
اذا المشاهدين المطارات السوريه بنك
الاهداف الاول للغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
السبب طبعا معروف النشاط الايراني
المتمركز وذلك عبر تلك المطارات ولذلك
تبذل اسرائيل كل الجهود العسكريه لتعطيل
وشن المطرات الرئيسيه في سوريا وقطع طريق
امداد مليشيات ايران سينما فايلق القدس
هناك صحيفه
مايا الروسيه الشهيره كشفت في تقرير لها
عن عزم اسرائيل منع عوده الحركه الجويه
بين روسيا سوريا عذرا وايران نهائيا لان
المسارات تستخدم لنقل الاسلحه الصحيفه
اوضحت ان المسؤولين الاسرائيليين يستكشفون
خيارات مختلفه بما فيها تعطيل المطارات
السوريه باعتبار ان ايران لجات للمطارات
المدنيه لنقل الاسلحه الى منشياتها بسبب
خوفها من نقلها بريا وفيما يتعلق باليه
تنفيذ التهديد الاسرائيلي نقلت صحيفه
الروسيه عن قولي لنا اسرائيليين ان ابسط
نهج سيكون هو في ضرب طائرات مهام اير
اثناء وجودها على الاراضي السوريه لكن
النظر الى تاثير عمليه من هذا النوع في
مطارات مدنيه يدفع الاسرائيليين للتفكير
بخيارات اختراق البناء التحتيه للمطار هذا
يكون عن طريق تعطيل المطار المدني
باستهداف المحطات الراداريه او محطات
الارشاد والتوجيه اللاسلكي في المطار ما
يحول الطائره الى طائره عمياء في الجو
خيار يعتبر مفيد اكثر من ضرب المدرج لان
اصلاح الاخير لا يتطلب وقتا طويلا اما
ضربات الراداريه فيتطلب جلب محطات جديده
من روسيا كون المحطات الحاليه الروسيه ما
يعني اخراج المطار عن الخدمه لفتره اطول
بحسب خبراء طيران سوريا
[موسيقى]